et de la diaspora de l'algérie
ce mineur
au nom de dieu clément et miséricordieux
prières et bénédictions sur le prophète
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale monsieur le secrétaire général
excellences mesdames et messieurs il me
plaît de prime abord de présenter mes
sincères félicitations
à son excellence monsieur ado la chahid
pour son élection à la présidence de la
66e session de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies en lui souhaitant plein
succès dans ses fonctions
je tiens également à rendre hommage à
votre prédécesseur monsieur volkan
bosquet pour son excellente gestion des
travaux de la précédente session et pour
toutes les initiatives louables
adopté sous sa présidence
je ne saurais d'ailleurs faillir aux
devoirs de réitérer notre appréciation
sincère au secrétaire général des
nations unies son excellence monsieur
antonio goûter pêche
ainsi que notre soutien à son engagement
en faveur du renforcement
du rôle de l'organisation des nations
unies en particulier dans les domaines
de la paix de la sécurité du
développement durable et de la
protection et de la promotion des droits
de l'homme
monsieur le président
cette session se tient au moment où
notre monde fait face à de nombreux
défis qui ont jeté une ombre sur tous
les aspects de la vie humaine
il ne fait aucun doute que la pandémie
de coved 19 en raison de sa propagation
rapide et de son aspect fatale
transcendant toutes les frontières
géographiques sans distinction entre
pays riches et pays pauvres un se trouve
aujourd'hui en tête de ces défis
existentielle
cette situation
confirme plus que jamais la nécessité
urgente
de renforcer la coopération et la
solidarité internationale
d'activer plus efficacement les
mécanismes d'action multilatéraux et ce
pour faire face conjointement à cette
pandémie et mettre en place les bases
d'un nouvel ordre mondial poste qu'ovide
répondant aux normes d'équité et
permettant d'assurer une participation
égale de toutes les nations
de tous les états membres des nations
unies sur la moindre discrimination à
cet égard le thème un de cette cession
traduit les principaux éléments pour le
renforcement des perspectives de
l'action multilatérale qui demeure la
seule voie susceptible de nous permettre
de surmonter cette phase décisive dans
l'histoire de l'humanité
dans ce cadre et en dépit des grands
défis qu'elle nous a imposé cette
pandémie nous offre également une
opportunité historique de réparer les
erreurs du passé et de tirer les leçons
afin d'avancer fermement sur la voie de
la construction d'un avenir prospère
pour toute l'humanité
pour ce faire nous sommes appelés à
oeuvrer en vue de faire aboutir le
processus de réforme globale de
l'organisation des nations unies afin
d'améliorer ses performances et de
renforcer ses capacités à assumer les
mandats qui lui sont attribués en vertu
de la charte de l'organisation
en mettant l'accent sur la
revitalisation du rôle central de
l'assemblée jeunesse râle et la réforme
du conseil de sécurité de manière à
garantir plus de transparence et une
représentation géographique équitable
met enfin à l'injustice historique que
subit le continent africain
[Musique]
monsieur le président
le contexte extraordinaire et dangereux
que vit la communauté internationale
aujourd'hui à l'aune de la pandémie de
kobe 19 ne doit pas nous faire oublier
les crises politiques et sécuritaires
les foyers de tension ainsi que les
défis de développement auxquels font
face de nombreuses régions du monde en
particulier au moyen orient et en
afrique
l'algérie
pays pivot
qui oeuvrent pour la paix et la
coopération
suit avec beaucoup d'intérêt les récents
développements intervenus dans plusieurs
pays frères et réitère sa position
inchangée en faveur de la promotion de
solutions pacifiques et politique à ces
conflits et crises loin de toute forme
d'ingérence étrangère
position dont laval a dit dont la
validité est l'importance sont
constamment confirmer sur le terrain
dans cet esprit mon pays s'est engagé
dans de nombreux efforts aux niveaux
régional et international afin de
s'attaquer aux causes profondes de ces
crises et conflits et pour retrouver la
stabilité en défendant les valeurs de
dialogue de négociation et de
réconciliation
nationale
mon pays continuera de défendre les
causes justes des peuples qui luttent
pour le recouvrement de leurs droits
fondamentaux
et légitimes y compris le droit
inaliénable à l'autodétermination
notamment en palestine et au sahara
occidental
dans ce contexte l'algérie exprime sa
profonde préoccupation face à l'absence
de perspective d'une solution juste et
définitive de la question palestinienne
et condamne la persistance des pratiques
répressives de l'occupation israélienne
contre le peuple palestinien frère
nous exprimons également
notre ferme condamnation du déni total
par israël du processus de paix et des
résolutions pertinentes des nations
unies et de la légalité internationale
nous renouvelons notre appel à la
communauté sion à la communauté
internationale et plus particulièrement
au conseil de sécurité afin d'assumer
ses responsabilité historique et légal
et contraindre la puissance occupante à
mettre fin à son occupation des
territoires palestiniens et permettre au
peuple palestinien d'établir un état
indépendant avec al qods al charif comme
capitale l'algérie réitère également son
engagement en faveur de l'initiative de
paix arabe visant à consacrer la
solution des deux états et à libérer
tous les territoires arabes occupés y
compris le golan syrien
avec la même détermination
l'algérie réaffirme son soutien au droit
du peuple sahraoui à l'autodétermination
nous appelons les nations unies à
assumer leur responsabilité juridique
envers le peuple sahraoui et à garantir
les droits inaliénables de ce dernier
l'organisation d'un référendum libre et
équitable pour permettre à ce peuple
vaillant de déterminer son destin et de
décider son avenir politique ne peut
rester à jamais l'otage de
l'intransigeance d'un état occupant qui
a failli à plusieurs reprises à ses
obligations internationales
en particulier
les responsabilités et obligations
découlant clairement du plan de
règlement élaboré par l'organisation des
nations unies en partenariat avec
l'organisation de l'unité africaine
ainsi que celles découlant de toutes les
résolutions pertinentes du conseil de
sécurité et de l'assemblée générale
le droit et la légalité internationale
se sont exprimés sur cette question ce à
travers les résolutions du conseil de
sécurité ainsi que l'avis consultatif
rendez par la rendue par la cour
internationale de justice il ya de cela
quatre des six nuits et qui témoigne de
la vraie nature du conflit au sahara
occidental
en ce qu'il constitue une question de
décolonisation qui ne peut trouver de
solution qu'à travers l'application du
principe d'autodétermination
c'est sur la base de ce même principe
que l'algérie pays voisins et
observateurs du processus politique
que
nous tentons de rester une source de
paix de sécurité et de stabilité pour
notre voisinage dont considérons que le
droit du peuple sahraoui à
l'autodétermination et inaliénable non
négociable et imprescriptibles
dans ce contexte l'algérie appuie la
décision du conseil de paix et de
sécurité de l'union africaine
de lancer des négociations directes
entre le royaume du maroc et la
république arabe sahraouie démocratique
deux pays membres de l'union africaine
cela de cela découle des devoirs et
responsabilités
vis-à-vis des principes et objectifs de
l'union africaine monsieur le président
sous la direction du président de la
république monsieur abdelmajid tebboune
et de par son histoire et son
appartenance à l'espace
arabe africain
islamique et méditerranéen l'algérie
reste fidèle aux valeurs et idéaux du
mouvement des pays non alignés
nous demeurons attachés aux objectifs et
principes de la charte des nations unies
et aspirons à travers tous nos efforts a
consacré la logique du dialogue comme
base pour le règlement des crises et
conflits nous continuons à nous opposer
aux mesures unilatérales
coercitives imposer aux pays en
développement
comme moyen pour exercer une pression
politique et économique en dehors de la
légalité internationale
la presse algérienne de règlement des
différends et des conflits s'est
matérialisé notamment en libye
lorsque nous avons apporté notre soutien
au processus de dialogue national entre
les frères libyens sous les auspices de
l'organisation des nations unies nous
avons redynamisé et continueront de
redynamiser le mécanisme des pays
voisins de la libye dont la dernière
réunion ministérielle s'est tenue à
alger avec pour objectif de contribuer à
la stabilité souhaitée dans ce pays à
travers le processus de paix et la tenue
des élections générales
conformément à la feuille de route
émanant du processus de dialogue
politique
inter-libyen
et ce afin de préserver la sécurité et
la stabilité de la libye ainsi que celle
des états voisins
directement affecté par tout ce qui se
produit dans ce pays frère
l'algérie est prête
à poursuivre
à poursuivre ses efforts et son soutien
aux frères libyens et à partager avec
eux
notre expérience en matière de
réconciliation nationale et de règlement
pacifique des conflits
nous appuierons donc nos frères libyens
afin de leur permettre de bénéficier de
notre expérience
c'est l'engagement
exprimé à maintes reprise par monsieur
le président de la république a dit
magyd t bone s'agissant de la situation
au mali
l'algérie est déterminée à poursuivre
son rôle à la tête du comité de l'accord
de paix et de réconciliation
issue du processus d'alger
il s'agit d'un rôle central et nous
félicitons des progrès enregistrés dans
ce cadre en dépit des grands défis et
difficultés engendrées par
l'expansion de la présence terroristes
qui menacent
la sécurité et la stabilité de ce pays
et de toute la région du sahel
et de tous les pays voisins
l'algérie renouvelle son attachement à
travailler de concert avec les frères
maliens afin de concrétiser les
objectifs et principes de l'accord
d'alger et nous attendons avec intérêt
la tenue des élections présidentielles
et la réalisation des objectifs de la
phase de transition
nous réitérons à cet égard notre appel à
la communauté internationale afin
d'apporter son soutien aux maliens et de
contribuer au succès de ce processus
notamment en honorant les engagements
pris en matière de développement
économique
et social
la situation dans ces deux pays
affecte directement la situation
d'instabilité que connaît la région
sahélo saharienne
et ce en raison de l'aggravation de la
menace terroriste et autres menaces
connexes
face à cette situation
le président de la république le sua des
magies tebboune en sa qualité de
coordonnateur de la lutte contre le
terrorisme et l'extrémisme violent en
afrique
a présenté des propositions pratiques à
la présidence de l'union africaine
visant à redynamiser les institutions et
renforcer les mécanismes dont dispose
l'union africaine dans la lutte contre
eux ce phénomène transfrontalier et
dangereux
le phénomène du terrorisme
dans la continuité de son action pour la
paix l'algérie poursuit ses efforts
visant à mettre fin aux différends et
à promouvoir les partenariats
stratégiques entre l'union africaine et
le monde arabe tout en préservant
l'unité africaine et en écartant tous
facteurs susceptibles de perturber cette
dernière ou de l'affecter de manière
négative
cette unité des rangs demeure la
condition essentielle à la réalisation
des objectifs stratégiques auxquels
aspirent les pays et les peuples du
continent à travers l'agenda
partant de cette conviction
l'algérie a répondu favorablement à la
demande des frères en ethiopie en egypte
et au soudan
en vue
d'apporter une contribution visant à
assurer un climat politique favorable
qui permettra à ces pays à ces pays
frères de dépasser leurs divergences et
faire valoir l'esprit de coopération et
d'intérêt commun
c'est
notre contribution vivante à faire
aboutir la médiation africaine monsieur
le président depuis l'adoption des
objectifs de développement durable
l'algérie a enregistré des progrès
significatifs dans la réalisation de ces
derniers
nous sommes aujourd'hui classée au
premier rang au niveau africain et arabe
ce fut le cas en 2019 dans le classement
indices de développement durable m
c est un indice de grande importance
concernant la mise en oeuvre des dix
sept objectifs du développement durable
concernant les questions
environnementales
l'algérie demeure préoccupé par
l'exacerbation des problèmes générés par
les crises environnementales multiples
et notamment le phénomène de
désertification qui affecte mon pays
depuis plusieurs décennies
l'aggravation continue des catastrophes
climatiques tels que les inondations les
sécheresses la rareté des précipitations
et les conséquences économiques et
sociales négatives qui en résultent
ainsi et que d'autres dommages causés
par le changement climatique et le
déclin alarmant de la bia biodiversité
en dépit de ses capacités limitées
l'algérie n'a ménagé aucun effort pour
relever les défis posés par ces
phénomènes
[Musique]
les questions
environnementales sont aujourd'hui un
élément important des politiques
de l'état
à différents niveaux
et dans divers secteurs
d'autre part mon pays poursuit fermement
le processus de consolidation de la
construction démocratique d'une algérie
nouvelle
avec la consécration de l'état de droit
et de la justice sociale
et ce notamment à travers l'amendement
de la constitution la tenue des
élections législatives et la préparation
en cours des prochaines élections
locales
le processus de changement démocratique
a été consacrée par le plan du
gouvernement adopté il y a quelques
jours
ce plan se compose de cinq axes
principaux
à savoir le renforcement de l'état de
droit et la consécration de la bonne
gouvernance la modernisation de la
justice la promotion des libertés
le dialogue la consultation et
l'établissement d'une société civile
libre et responsable ainsi que la
liberté de réunion de manifestation
pacifique de la presse et la lutte
contre la corruption la modernisation de
l'administration et de la fonction
publique toutes ces réformes politiques
traduisent
la volonté du peuple algérien et de
l'état algérien de renforcer les droits
de l'homme
au sens large sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire
dans le domaine économique le
gouvernement continue d'oeuvrer à
renforcer la relance économique à
moderniser le système bancaire et
financier à réformer le secteur public
commercial et la gouvernance des
institutions publiques ainsi qu'à
améliorer l'attractivité du climat
d'investissement et le cadre de
développement des entreprises et de
l'entrepreneuriat
monsieur le président
l'épreuve
existentielle que la pandémie de
qu'ovide 19 à imposer à l'humanité a mis
en évidence l'unité de notre destin
la communauté internationale doit donc
prendre conscience de la nécessité de
travailler main dans la main afin de
garantir un meilleur avenir à touches
c'est pourquoi l'humanité est
aujourd'hui face à une précieuse
opportunité
n'ont pas nécessairement de changer le
passé
mais de veiller à saisir la promesse
d'un nouvel élan
vers une nouvelle ère dans laquelle
tous les êtres humains
seront à l'abri de la peur et du besoin
ou tous les êtres humains pourront mener
une vie digne je vous remercie de votre
aimable attention et que la paix de dieu
soit avec vous tous
haïti je remercie le ministre des
affaires étrangères et de la diaspora de
l'algérie de son intervention